hundreds of people are rallying in
Istanbul in support of the mayor after a
court sentenced him to jail for
insulting public officials the trial
focused on remarks that ekram imamolu
made during the Mayoral race in 2019 if
the appeals court upholds the verdict it
would prevent him from holding public
office for the duration of the two-year
seven-month sentence imamolo is seen as
a potential Challenger to president
Richard
in parliamentary elections in the
Parliamentary election next year on
presidential election
Starbucks
this court case has proved that there is
no justice left in Turkey this case is
led by people who don't want to bring
the values such as Justice and democracy
to Turkey in fact this is a case which
was shamelessly influenced and decided
by the people who claim ownership of
everything see themselves as the state
and the nation
let's bring in Tariq oguslo a professor
of political science and international
relations with Istanbul Aden University
he joins us now live from there good to
have you with us Professor what do you
make of the Court's verdict obviously
the mayor claims that it's politically
motivated what are you making it
it's for sure that this particular event
will have some political consequences
regarding the upcoming presidential and
parliamentary elections the opposition
people are simply saying that the links
between the government and the Judiciary
has been well established so it would
have been impossible for the Judiciary
to take such kind of a very important
decision in a very important environment
right now but we also know that the
government authorities should have
recognized the fact that this kind of an
event would have some repercussions in
the upcoming elections so my own opinion
is that the government
has not been directly involved in such
kind of a case because the final outcome
would be very much
not in their interns it's for sure
because what happened in the past when
President erdogan was mayor of Istanbul
he was put into prison just for the fact
that he
read a poem for example so this
particular event had boosted his
credentials to become a a president
prime minister and president of the
country so the same scenario might even
might evolve in the context of a mayor
of Istanbul criminal although so it
would have been quite
impossible to think that the government
took a very important action in pushing
the Court members to take such kind of a
decision but we all know that it is
inevitable that this particular event
will have some credit card consequences
because nowadays the government the
opposition parties have come together
and they have been continuously saying
that
the mayor of Istanbul has put in an
unjustice situation so the people in the
upcoming elections will teach a lessons
to the current Administration so they
think that the chances of the opposition
to get elected will increase the latest
decision as you say the but this is
almost history repeating itself here
isn't it because the same thing happened
to president Richard when he was mayor
of Istanbul
you are right that that's the point I
was trying to underline that's why I was
also saying that and it would be
impossible for the government to not to
think the potential consequences of such
kind of a situation I think in this
particle is that the case the Court
members took a decision uh without
taking into account any political
consequences because the the particular
circles that would benefit from such
kind of a situation are the oppositional
circles not not the incubate government
so so mayor erdogan went on to become
president uh the same the same thing
could happen with the current position
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah given this
situation I mean how would it be
possible to think that the government
very much encouraged the court numbers
to take that kind of a decision onto
them also from political life and it
would have been committing suicide on
the particular side so that's why I'm
saying that in this particular case the
code numbers took this decision
independently that's my own idea that's
one of opinion of course but nowadays in
today's turkey uh interpreting such kind
of politically important events from an
objective size is quite difficult so
what we are doing is somehow offering a
kind of speculative statement Professor
it's been really good to talk to you
many thanks indeed for being with us
here on the news now my station
calculation